bonjour nous sommes jeudi 8 janvier
merci de nous rejoindre dans filecho
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
locale c'est notre première émission de
l'année une émission un peu particulière
en cette journée de deuil national comme
vous le savez elle a été décrétée en
raison de l'attentat terroriste qui
s'est déroulé qui s'est déroulé hier
midi dans les locaux du journal Charlie
Hebdo nous y reviendrons juste après les
titres de cette
édition en ce début d'année les
syndicats et représentants patronal ont
présenté leurs vœux pour 2015 leur
discours suit la ligne de 2014 la grogne
est toujours d'actualité en 2015 de
nouvelles réformes et mesures sont
attendues nous vous présenterons les
grandes lignes et ce qui vous attend
nous reviendrons enfin sur la
préparation et le premier jour des
solldes qui a eu lieu hier nous verrons
si les consommateurs yvinois sont
toujours au rendez-vous hop et nous
reviendrons 3 avec Gilles ruot donc le
le le excusez-moi le directeur
départemental de la protection des
populations nous reviendrons avec lui
sur le phénomène des soldes mais avant
cela place à l'actualité de cette
semaine avec toute la rédaction nous
tenions à rendre encore une fois un
hommage aux 12 victimes du terrible
attentat terroriste qui a touché les
locaux de Charlie hebbdo hier les les
caricaturistes très connus Charb Kabu
volinski et new font parti de ses
victimes lui n'était pas dessinateur
mais économiste et chroniqueur sur
France Inter terre
euh Bernard Maris est mort dans une
tuerie il avait 68 ans actionnaire de
Charlie abdo depuis 1992 il rédigeait
dans lesdomadair satirique chaque
semaine une chronique signé oncle
Bernard considéré comme antilibéral il
défendait une économie de répartition
des richesses le kénésianisme et la
relance par la hausse des revenus et de
la consommation tout nos pensées vont
bien sûr aux proches et aux familles des
victimes de cet attentat qui qui touche
profondément chacun d'entre
nous en ce en ce début d'année chacun
souhaite la reprise économique les
organisations syndicales et patronales
se sont exprimé sur leurs souhait et
objectifs pour 2015 le MDEF des ivines a
présenté ses vœux hier avant de
prononcer son discours Bertrand de Cré
le président a rendu un hommage aux
victimes de l'attentat de Charlie Hebdo
il est ensuite revenu sur les
mobilisations de décembre ainsi que sur
le mécontentement à l'encontre du
gouvernement
écoutez-le une grande isation de notre
syndicat en décembre dernier il y a à
des discussions qui sopèent entre Pierre
Gata du gouvernement alors si N
nobtenons pas satisfaction si les
blocages persistent il est possible
qu'il y ait que la réponse soit graduée
et qu'on ait d'autresisations mais il
est trop tôt pour en parler aujourd'hui
nos entreprises on non ralb il y a un
vrai ralb d'entrepreneur qui qui ne sont
pas totalement découragés ils ont
l'espoir quand même et et pour moi la
crise n'est pas une fatalité mais si
j'ai un vœu à formuler c'est arrêter
d'entraver les bonnes volontés et
laissz-les tirer la croissance que la
croissance elle se décrète pas elle se
fabrique une grne également entendue du
côté des représentants des cadres et des
classes moyennes pas de trêve en ce
début d'année selon Jean-François labord
président union départementale CFE CGC
ce que nous attendons de la part du
gouvernement c'est un certain nombre
d'actions concrètes pour rétablir lire
l'emploi donc arrêter cette chute du
chômage parce que cette chute du chômage
ben ça entraîne tous nos systèmes
sociaux en France donc c'est la première
attente mais également l'attente très
forte de la CF CGC c'est qu'on arrête de
taper sur les classes moyennes qu'on
arrête de taper sur les cadres nous
sommes plumés sans arrêt nous avons en
2015 nous allons prendre plein pot les
effets des décisions sur les impôts qui
ont été prises en 2014 certes on annonce
qu'il y aura pas de nouvelles de
nouveaux impôts mais les décisions ont
été pris en 2014 vont rentrer en vigueur
en 2015 donc là maintenant ça suffit
l'année 2015 vient de commencer avec
elle son lot de changement sur le plan
économique voici un rapide aperçu des
nouvelles lois augmentation suppression
ou diminution qui vont impacter notre
quotidien mais surtout l'économie
française 2015 année de la reprise
économique un peu trop tôt pour le dire
déjà des ajustements ont eu lieu dès le
1er janvier ainsi les quatre premiers
facteurs de pénibilité du travail sont
dès à présent pris en compte pour les
salariés effectuant un emploi physique
en dépit des manifestations des patrons
ces derniers avaient demandé en décembre
une concertation à ce sujet avec le
gouvernement patrons et entreprises
verront l'entrée en vigueur du premier
volet du pacte de responsabilité une
suppression progressive de l'impôt sur
la production et la baisse des charges
sur les petits salaires inférieur à 1,6
% du SMIC en 2015 le droit à la
formation individuelle pour les salariés
disparaît au profit du compte personnel
de formation quant à l'âge légal du
départ en retraite il devrait
globalement reculer cela pour combler le
déficit des retraites qui devrait
avoisiner les 15 milliards d'euros d'ici
2020 côté fiscalité les foyers aux
revenus moyens et modestes vont
bénéficier de la suppression de l'impôt
sur la première tranche 6,1 million de
foyers vont en profiter il faudra ainsi
au ménag avoir un revenu de 10000 € par
part individuelle pour commencer à être
imposable contre 6000 € auparavant
parlons maintenant des augmentations
certaines sont attendues comme le
montant du RSA revenu solidarité active
il augmente de 0,9 % une personne seule
percevra ainsi
513,88 € par mois d'autres augmentations
moins attendues celles-ci seront
d'actualité 1,8 % en plus pour les
tarifs règl Moné du gaz la redevance
télévisée va gonfler de 3 € pour passer
à 136 €. la Poste revoit elle aussi à la
hausse le prix de ces timbre de 7 %.
concernant les transports là aussi les
questions d'augmentation la prochaine
une fois que vous prendrez le taxi votre
course sera majorée de 1 % quant au
billets TGV Intercité et TER il devrait
être 2,6 % plus cher enfin les forfaits
Navigo augmentent eux aussi et passent à
116,50 € au lieu de 113,20 € pour les
zones de 1 à 5 unôt en moins taxe en
plus le gouvernement assure qu'il
n'augmentera pas les impôts pour cette
nouvelle année mais cela n'empêchera pas
la hausse des prixs
réglementé il est maintenant temps de
passer au solde avec notre entretien de
la semaine
dans cet entretien cette semaine je vous
disais nous allons aborder la question
des soldes les soldes qui ont commencé
hier nous sommes je le rappelle avec
Gill Ruau bonjour vous êtes directeur
départemental de la protection de la
population des Yvelines vous avez
notamment en charge la protection
économique du consommateur alors pour
pour commencer il y a du nouveau sur les
sols maintenant on passe à 6 semaines
est-ce que vous pouvez m'en dire un
petit peu plus oui alors cette année en
2014 enfin cette année voté en 2014 et
applicable au 1er janvier 2015 la
période des soldes donc est passée de 5
à 6 semaines avec la suppression de ce
qu'on appeler les soldes flottant
c'est-à-dire des périodes qui
permettaient aux commerçants de faire
des soldes en dehors des périodes
habituelles hiver été euh donc pour
assurer une meilleure visibilité donc
des opérations de soldes une
simplification a été votée par le
Parlement qui maintenant donne une
visibilité sur 6 semaines de soldes en
été et en hiver donc les soldes on
commen lancé le 7 janvier jusqu'au 17
février alors les les soldes flottant
avaient été voté en en 2008 avec la loi
LME pourquoi ça n'a pas été un succès
hein ça n'a pas été un succès les
professionnels finalement se sont
aperçus qu'il y avait que que cela
entraine une certaine confusion dans
l'esprit du consommateur qui est
lui-même sollicité par différentes
opérations de promotion de vente privée
donc dans un souci encore une fois de
simplification et de meilleure
visibilité le législateur a souhaité
reprendre j'allais dire les dispositions
sur les soldes en simplifiant et en ne
donnant qu'une seule qu'une seule durée
une durée de 6 semaines pendant les deux
périodes donc saisonnières été hiver
alors justement vous parlez des ventes
privées elles ont lieu juste avant les
soldes donc ce sont les magasins qui
invitent le leurs clients fidèles à
revenir est-ce que c'est vraiment voilà
ça ça ça entache les soldes c'est
vraiment légal parce qu'on peut se dire
voilà c'est un peu des soldes avant les
soldes finalement ces opérations de
vente privée sont en soi légales dans la
mesure où elle permettent aux
commerçants pour une partie de sa
clientèle de leur proposer des produits
donc à prix réduit une une exigence
d'abord une une exigence concernant le
public doit pas en effet il faut pas que
ces ventes concernent donc un public
trop important et deuxièmement un point
plus technique il ne faut pas que ces
produits soient revendus à perte alors
que les solodes permettent bien entendu
de de de le faire cela étant les
services de Direction Départementale
protection les gens sont vigilants sur
sur ce type de vente privée hein qui en
soit sont tout à fait légales alors
justement par rapport donc à votre
fonction est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus nous expliquer en quoi
cela consiste comment vous organisez
qu'est-ce que vous réglementez
exactement très précisément et peut-être
concrètement aussi très concrètement
d'abord il y a un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires d'agents de la direction
protection et population qui Assur donc
la surveillant ces opérations de solld
selon j'allais dire deux grands
principes un problème un principe de
proportionnalité c'est en fait dans les
magasins les les agents les contrôleurs
les inspecteurs vérifient que il y a une
proportionnalité des remises qui sont
accordées quand on décide par exemple
d'une remise de 50 60 % voir plus il
faut bien entendu que cela concerne un
nombre significatif d'articles ça c'est
le premier point donc proportionnalité
et le second principe véracité en fait
il faut que les remises qui sont
proposées soient réellement effectué
est-ce qu'on vous signale peut-être plus
d'abus pendant les sols est ce sont les
consommateurs ou les commerçants enfin
comment ça se passe alors les
consommateurs surtout maintenant avec
l'usage fréquent d'Internet n'hésite pas
à nous écrire à nous envoyer des mails
pour nous signaler que ils ont constaté
qu'un article soi-disant un prix réduit
ne l'était pas ou découvre sur
l'étiquette ou sur la deuxième étiquette
un prix barré qui ne correspond pas à
celui véritablement pratiqué dans ce
cas-là il n'hésite pas et pour nous bien
entendu c'est un je va dire un indice
c'est c'est une information utile qui
est utilisée par les services alors
comment vous procédez-vous on est je
sais pas dans les magasins enfin
incognito ou comment ça se passe non il
y a pas de bien que la loi maintenant le
prévoit hein le client mystère don en a
beaucoup parlé donc le plus souvent bien
entendu les agents
donc interviennent visage découvert en
montrant leur commission d'emploi bien
entendu en indiquant professionnel qu'il
vont
donc mettre en place un contrôle dans
les principaux bien sûr magasins grandes
enseignes mais aussi sur sur Internet
puisque vous savez que une grande partie
des soldes et notamment des soldes
divers sont réalisés sur Internet ce qui
est une exception un peu française
puisque la France reste le consommateur
Françis reste très attaché au sol et
justement est-ce qu'il y a peut-être
plus de risque sur internet il faut être
plus plus vigilant par rapport je sais
pas au produits qu'on va
acheter plus vigant jeallis dire oui par
définition d'abord parce que le produit
vous le vous le voyez pas donc il faut
vraiment être bien bien regarder les
informations
l'étiquetage bien entendu qui sont
indiqué et qui sont oblig bien sûr sur
internet il faut surtout que le
consommateur lui aussi sache quel
produit il veut vraiment acheter donc il
est lui-même fait lui-même sa propre sa
propre réflexion bien entendu encore
plus lorsque l'on achète sur un site
virtuel alors si par exemple moi cliente
j'achète un produit sur Internet et qui
la réduction ne me convient pas ou enfin
que qu'il y a un souci comment ça se
passe comment je peux me me mettre en
contact avec vous pour régler ce
problème il peut bien sûr saisir la
Direction Départementale donc la
consommation des ilines TR jeanmerm puis
on aussi un mail
ddpp@ine.gouf.fr he faut faire des
photos il faut alors bien entendu bien
entendu tout tout élément probant est
utile photos ou exemplaire de exemplaire
d'étiquette et cetera bien entendu tout
cela est tout à fait utile à quel à quel
risque s'exposent voilà les personnes
qui les commerçants qui font des des
mauvaises enfin qui qui vendent les au
mauvais prix ou comment ça se ça rgors
c'est ces pratiques peuvent être
qualifié de pratique commerciales
trompeuses hein donc il y a des
sanctions pénales qui peuvent être
fortes hein qui peuvent être bien
entendu prononcé par le juge par exemple
quellees sanctions vous pouvez me donner
des exemples des sanctions d'amende bien
sûr principalement qui peuvent qui
peuvent monter sur à peu près 15000
20000 € hein mais aussi bien entendu le
plus souvent donc des injonctions
administratives hein de de de modifier
des publicités par exemple peuvent être
prises par les agents quel conseil
donneriez-vous au consommateurs afin
voilà d'être plus vigilant et de ne pas
se faire avoir justement d'abord je
pense qu'il faut et beaucoup de
consommateurs le font faire un petit
repérage dans les soldes hein bien
entendu qui concerne je vous rappelle
principalement le textile hein donc
l'abillement et puis les chaussures tout
ce qui est équipement de la
personne ensuite d'être vigilant sur des
remises qui paraissent un peu importante
très très
importante donc là aussi peut-être se
dire qu'il vaut mieux peut-être une
remise qui soit vraiment réel à un prix
un prix plus bas plutôt que de se
laisser tenter par des remises un peu un
peu ronflantes qui sont pas toujours
réalisé enfin Gill r Je tenais à revenir
avec vous sur les événements d'hier donc
après l'attentat de Charlie abdo le plan
vigip pirate a été élevé au niveau
alerte attentat tout de suite les grands
magasins ont été prévenus c'est le cas
notamment à l'espace Saint-Quentin je
vous propose d'écouter Alix Anne
directrice de l'espace
Saint-Quentin on a reçu un appel à
partir de peu près midi et demi donc
informant de la du la hausse de du plan
VI pirate et nous demandant de mettre en
place des mesures adapté et notamment de
renforcer notre sécurité donc de manière
immédiate on a renforcé à chaque entrée
avec un contrôle systématique des sacs
un contrôle visuel pour
vérifier chaque
sac c'est surtout donc de rassurer le
client de vérifier que tout se passe
bien d'être vigilant sur individu sup
colis suspect de toute façon le plan
Vigipirate était déjà en place nous on
l'avait déjà renforcé on va dire au mois
de décembre là on l'a intensifié avec un
contrôle à chaque entrée on a par
ailleurs informé l'ensemble de nos
commerçants j'étais sur le terrain avec
toutes mes équipes pour informer les
commerçants alors même que certains
n'étaient même pas au courant que ce
matin il y avait eu un attentat donc on
a aussi expliqué aux gens le pourquoi
est-ce qui s'était passé pour suite à
cette hausse du niveau et là donc moi je
suis en ligne aussi bien avec la mairie
le commissariat la direction de
l'hypermarché pour faire en sorte que on
ait les meilleures infos et qu'on soit
cohérent sur notre
intervention une réaction par rapport
donc à à ce ce témoignage est-ce que
vous avez aussi des directives à
suivre les directiv d'abord en tant que
service de l'État bien entendu nous
avons procédé donc à la cérémonie de
minutes de silence donc prévu par le
Président de la République et relayé
bien sûr par Monsieur le Préfet
desivelin j'ai donner aussi des
instructions au chef de service et et
aux agents pour qu'il soient aussi
prudents bien entendu dans leur démarche
et vigilant puisque c'est le terme
vigilance qui qui qui importe bien
entendu les contrôles et bien entendu
l'activité économique ne doit pas
s'interrompre ce qui ser d'aille un
cadeau à faire à ceux qui mettent en
péril de la République donc si on bien
entendu nous respectons comme les
professionnels le fond bien entendu les
les précautions et la vigilance
l'activité économique continuera
sans être affecté notamment pendant
cette P de sol vous pensez que c ne va
pas impacter les sols que les consturs
ne vont pas avoir peur pas je je ne
pense pas que ça va impacter donc les
achats des clients merci beaucoup Gilles
ruot d'être venu avec nous sur notre
plateau je vous propose maintenant de
passer au chiffres de la
semaine pardon excusez-moi c'était le le
dossier de la semaine nous restons
d'ailleurs sur les soldes elles ont
commencé hier et vont durer 6 semaines
donc jusqu'au 17 février à cette
occasion nous avons suivi des
commerçants et des clients dans la
préparation et leur organisation
regardez ce dossier sur les soldes
réalisé avec William l j-1 avant les
soldes et déjà certains clients ont pris
les devants pour faire du repérage oui
voir déjà grosso modo les articles pour
pouvoir rapidement avoir les articles
avec les bonnes tailles je cherche un
jeans tout simplement j'ai deux filles
donc pour ma grande j'attends souvent
les soldes pour euh pour la saison
prochaine inutile de chercher en rayon
les - 20- 40 ou - 50 % tant espéré par
les acheteurs la veille des soldes les
commerçants et vendeurs préparent les
étiquettes et leur stock en toute
discrétion aucun prix ne doit être
visible avant la date d'ouverture fixée
par la préfecture vous avez donc tous
les produits en fait qui sont en fait en
cours de préparation enfin pour cela
c'est quasiment en fait prêt donc qui
vont arriver en fait dans le rayon ce
soir on va travailler très tard dans
cette boutique de linge de maison haut
de gamme 5000 produits doivent être
réétiquetés pour cela le nombre
d'employés a doublé moi par exemple
d'habitude je travaille pas en fait dans
le magasin on a une jeune fille qui
travaille aussi derrière nous donc qui
est aussi étudiante en école de commerce
qui vientent nous aider et donner main
forte pour la préparation des produits
faut ouvrir tous les produits faire une
étiquette qui soit adaptée à la couleur
à la référence et qui indique donc les
trois niveaux de prix selon les magasins
l'organisation est plus ou moins
fastidieuse mais toujours essentielle un
Français sur deux effectue des achats
liés au soldes dans le secteur de la
conf tion 40 % des articles sont vendus
pendant cette période aujourd'hui c'est
la dernière journée où on peut un peu
souffler avant demain et toutes les tout
le mois qui arrive on s'arrange que tout
soit bien nickel dans magasin que tout
soit rangé pour pouvoir ce soir
étiqueter au plus vite et pouvoir
pouvoir avoir des promotions rapidement
que demain tout soit prêt pour les
clients quand ils arrivent cette année
les soldes seront plus longues 6
semaines au lieu de 5 habituellement
auparavant les commerçants bénéficiaient
de 2 semaines de solde flottante cette
mesure relative à la loi LME de 2008 a
été supprimé depuis cet été les sol
flotant c'était un petit peu compliqué
même pour la clientèle dans le sens où
alors il y a les sols les sol flotants
les opérations commerciales il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses voilà ça va
pas enlever en fait de période de
réduction pour la clientèle mais par
contre c'est un peu plus concentré la
préparation continue demain la plupart
des centres commerciaux ouvr plus tôt
pour accueillir les premiers
clients et le mercredi des 8h30 à
SaintQuentin en ivine habituellement ils
arrivent est plutôt vers 9h 9h30 et
c'est à 10h que ça commence à
être bien chaud jusqu'à 18h on va dire
donc là ça commence bien comme ça la
journée va passer
vite avant de se rendre au travail ou en
cours certains se sont levés plusut tôt
pour profiter des bonnes affaires et
éviter ainsi les mains de foule
j'accompagne ma fille au collège ça
correspond P poil à l'ouverture des
magasins et heureusement que ça ça
s'ouvre à 8h30 parce que ça me donne
plus de courage après je sais qu'and ça
part vite alors j'ai absolument voulu
venir à l'ouverture donc voilà so moins
50 % c'est intéressant ouais des remises
nécessair pour doper les ventes sur les
trois premières semaines des soldes
d'été de 2014 une baisse de 4 % avait
été enregistrée sur l'habillement et le
textile par rapport à 2013 pour contrer
ce phénomène les commerçants ont mis en
place des rabais importants je les avais
repérés hier ouais et du coup ouais je
vais les acheter elles sont à 40 % donc
ça me l' fait à 60 € donc donc voilà
c'est une bonne affaire je pense ouais
les réductions là je suis sur du - 60
sur une petite chemise un petit gilet
style collège un petit t-shirt ambiance
montagne et un petit gilet collège donc
voilà donc - 60 ça va c'est appréciable
les consommateurs toujours attachés au
soldes oui mais de plus en plus vigilant
pour Philippe fleuret président de
l'association locale UFC Que Choisir à
Versailles les promotions flottantes ou
le phénomène des Vendes privées ont
changé les habitudes les enseignes en
principe essa de de valoriser ces ventes
privées et de faire en sorte de de de on
va dire de flatter entre guillemets le
consommateur en disant vous êtes un
client privilégié c'est un produit haut
de gamme voyez donc il y a une
considération accrue vis-à-vis de la
clientèle mais je dirais ça ce sont des
techniques marketing et donc ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est la différence
entre les soldes et les promotions les
soldes ce sont des stock de marchandises
qui n'ont pas été vendu au cours au
moins au moins au cours du mois
précédent donc qui sont vendu avec des
rabés alors que les promotions
généralement ce sont des des
fabrications spécifiques dans le cadre
d'une promotion les commerçant restent
optimistes ils espèrent écouler le stock
de vêtements chauds peu vendu avec les
températures douces de ce début d'hiver
selon un sondage Ifop près de 76 % des
Français vont faire des achats durant
ces soldes d'hivers mais pour un tiers
d'entre eux ce sera uniquement sur
internet un dernier Modot des soldes 172
€ c'est le budget moyen des Français
pour les soldes d'hivers 2015 c'est
notre chiffre de la semaine cette
estimation est tirée d'un sondage de
l'Ifop il rappelle que la somme
consacrée au soldes a baissé déjà cet
été le budget alloué à ses dépenses
était de 182 € l'année dernière pour la
même période le budget moyen des
Français était de 205 €. c'est bientôt
la fin de notre émission il est
maintenant temps de passer à l'agenda de
la
semaine demain vendredi la CGPME des
iines organise son 3ème module de
réunion d'information concernant la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
cette réunion porte sur le compte
personnel de formation qui remplace le
droit individuel à la formation le
rendez-vous est fixé à 9h à à
rambouiller n'oubliez pas de vous
inscrire l'association BGE Eveline
organise plusieurs réunions
d'information à destination des futurs
chefs d'entreprise la prochaine a lieu
le vendredi 16 janvier de 9h à midi il
sera animé par un conseil professionnel
un conseiller professionnel pour
répondre à toutes vos questions la
réunion a lieu à épone là aussi il faut
s'inscrire enfin sachez que le grand
assemblement d'hommage aux victimes de
la tuerie de Charlie Hebdo aura lieu ce
dimanche 11 janvier je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivi je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée à la semaine prochaine dans
un prochain numéro de
Philco